I'm Pablo we the OTV babies hono Chapo
shy hey man we the first people to do
this West Coast drill out here man shout
out to my [__] bule Kev man for putting
us on the podcast bro I ain't going to
lie man we want everybody to tap in on
this [__] man even our Ops [__] this
[__] Hot [__] care bring this [__] to
California man this [__] West Coast
drill West Coast drill coming from OTB
baby OT OTB baby first
man shoot it shootter hang in there
Village babies OTV OTV kids what
up
stoping y gang me and you [__] is not
the same yeah y gang call my shoo a bust
a brain y gang me and you [__] is not
the
same y g twin Glocks I got
two Town my side of town say Y toown in
this [__] this that drill [__] West
[__] yeah this just what it is they just
double out the FED we still ride around
with a
sem we was on the Block we was outside
in the H yeah whole G gets dir 13
bullets Brock part we outside on the
Curby sipping lean till I'm slur pop a
perk now I'm F okay Angel my shirt being
broke my only demon typ to drop the walk
in a squirt anything to get us lean
shoot right by me not off a perk ready
to wet you up like the cleaners I need a
thick [__] like Megan me a bad [__]
like
[Music]
to a man down try to hit West weide with
check your background we play around [__]
cut ass out the
picture game smok [__] like a swi
[__] beeting for the fame they
attention I never give it y gang me you
[__] is not the
same y gang call my shy a bust a
brain G me and you [__] step the
same
g double trouble like the to my whole G
get fouble got a fig
forner like woke up
and dir the we don't fear n you [__] the
roof on
nigas
[__] smoke the [__] like I hate eating
only eating steak lober if you me give
me
all every every
here never did it for no Fame yeah
Village babies man we the hottest out
the city [__] y'all going to check this
[__] out man shout out to my [__] man
yeah
gang V babies out here man bir Vision
gang man hey appreciate you guys
watching this freestyle we got another
one coming and then another one and then
another one and they're all brought to
you by our good Folks at LRG clothing
you already know what it is LRG been
keeping you fly for years they got so
much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG